[Music]
whether she's describing bickering
families quiet declarations of love or
juicy gossip Jane Austen's writing often
field as it was written just for you her
dry wit and cheeky playfulness informs
her heroines whose conversational tone
welcomes readers with a conspiratorial
wink it's even been said that some
readers feel like the author's secret
confidant trading letters with their
delightfully wicked friend Jane but this
unique brand of tongue-in-cheek humor is
just one of the many feats found in her
slice satires of society civility and
sweeping romance written in the early
19th century Austen's novels decode the
sheltered life of the upper classes in
rural England from resentment couched in
pleasantries to arguing that maths
attraction her work explores the per
will during collision of emotions and
etiquette but while romance is a common
thread in her work Austen dismissed the
sentimental style of writing so popular
at the time instead of lofty love
stories her characters act naturally and
often awkwardly they trade pragmatic
advice friendly jokes and not so
friendly barbs about their arrogant
peers as they grapple with the endless
rules of their society Austen's
characters can usually find humor in all
the hypocrisy propriety and small talk
as mr. Bennet jokes to his favorite
daughter for what do we live but to make
sport for our neighbours and laugh at
them in our turn and though her heroines
might ridicule senseless social mores
Austen fully understood the practical
importance of maintaining appearances at
the time she was writing a wealthy
marriage was a financial necessity for
most young women and she often explores
the tension between the mythical quest
for love and the economic benefits of
making a match
the savvy socialite Mary Crawford sums
this up in Mansfield Park I would have
everybody marry if they can do it
properly I do not like to how people
throw themselves away unsurprisingly
these themes were also present in
Austen's personal life born in 1775 she
lived in the social circles found in her
novels Jane's parents supported her
education and provided a space for her
to write and publish her work
anonymously but writing was hardly
lucrative work and although she had
sparks of chemistry she never married
elements of her circumstances can be
found in many of her characters often
intelligent women with witty pragmatic
personalities and rich inner lives these
headstrong heroines provide an
entertaining anchor for their tumultuous
romantic narratives like the irreverent
Elizabeth Bennet of Pride and Prejudice
whose devotion to her sisters love lives
blinds her to a clumsy suitor or the
iron world Anne Elliot of persuasion who
chooses to remain unmarried offer the
disappearance of her first love and
Elinor Dashwood who fiercely protects
her family at the cost of her own
desires in Sense and Sensibility these
women all encounter difficult choices
about romantics filial and financial
stability and they resolve them without
sacrificing their values or their sense
of humor
of course these characters are far from
perfect they often think they have all
the answers and by telling the story
from their perspective Austen tricks the
viewer into believing their heroine
knows best only to pull the rug out from
under the protagonist and the reader in
Emma the titular character feels
surrounded by dull neighbors and friends
who can't hope to match her wit as her
guests prattle on and on about nothing
the reader begins to agree emma is the
only exciting character in this quiet
neighborhood
yet despite her swelling ego Emma may
not be as in control as she thinks in
life all love and Austen's intimate use
of perspective makes these revelations
doubly surprising blindsiding both
Emma and her audience but rather than
diminishing her host of heroines these
floors only confirm the inconsistency of
all human characters their complexity
has kept Austin prominent on stage and
screen and made her work easily
adaptable for modern sensibilities
so hopefully new readers will continue
to find a friend in Miss Austin for many
years to come if you're a fan of Jane
Austen check out this lesson on another
British literary giant writing 100 years
later
Virginia Woolf had a complicated ever
evolving admiration for Austen and she
might just be the author you need to
read next
[Music]